holy his moustache cop Casey Jones
from Ninja Turtles let me in classic
vampire phrase don't fall for that
alright so I personally have been told
by many people for months that I just
have to see the original Let The Right
One In I just have to and I haven't I
don't know what it is I just haven't
seen it so this review is from the eyes
of someone who has not seen the original
Let The Right One In and I have also
been told that the original Let The
Right One In is like the greatest
vampire movie ever made so I effectively
have seen the remake of the greatest
vampire story ever told but I would
honestly say it's not really a vampire
story it's not it's the story of a 12
year old socially awkward boy who gets
bullied in school and befriends a
vampire that would be like saying where
the wild things are is about tripping
balls in the woods it's really not about
that I mean the movie is really well
shot but when I watch a movie I always
have to think to myself how many times
will I end up watching this movie
willingly
I mean replay value matters and I want
to be perfectly honest with you guys
because I just love getting heat from
the community I found the movie to be
boring and I would probably just never
watch it again I mean I understand all
the meanings and the parables and the
undertones in the movie but you can
understand all the ingredients in haggis
and still not like how it tastes I mean
it's not without good there were some
things that I really liked in the movie
I mean it's really well acted the ending
was badass I mean the very end of the
movie has a shot that's like the coolest
shot that I've seen in a movie in quite
a while and there's a car crash scene
that's also that was good too but as for
the ending it doesn't change the fact
that I had to wait through two hours
that felt like for and saying yeah but
it's bull shot like that's supposed to
determine all that in a good movie is
like saying yeah but this Scotch is
well-made yeah but it still tastes like
burnt plastic and it's just not my thing
was let me in the greatest vampire movie
ever made if you couldn't tell by now no
I personally don't think so and if you
do think that Let Me In to the greatest
vampire movie ever made think of it this
way a year from now or so you mean give
it time think about what your second
favorite vampire movie is and if you've
seen it more than you've seen Let Me In
I Got News for you let me ins not your
favorite vampire movie I'm not gonna
call the movie dog because it
really wasn't but it was about as
interesting to me as the American was so
I'll give it the same rating it's
oscar-worthy
and by that I mean long boring drawn-out
and dull it's a - atif Falls it's well
acted well shot a couple of cool thing
it's too long and boring just not my
thing but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]